es la culminación de las crecientes
tensiones entre argelia y marruecos
el martes argel rompió formalmente los
lazos diplomáticos con rabat francés
ciertos factores y detalles previamente
mencionados argelia ha decidido el día
de hoy romper los lazos diplomáticos con
el reino de marruecos en el joe los dos
países han estado enfrentados durante
décadas por la región del sáhara
occidental en el norte de áfrica al
final de 2020 marrocos normalizar sus
relaciones con israel y como parte de un
pacto diplomático con estados unidos
accedió a reconocer las reclamaciones de
rabat sobre el sáhara occidental' parte
él rechazó la decisión declarando que
contradicen las resoluciones de la onu y
que perjudicaría a los esfuerzos de
desescalada entre ambos países argelia
asegura que marruecos apoyo a grupos
separatistas argelinos que buscan la
independencia la región de cabilia en el
norte una de las cuales considera como
una organización terrorista y que
también acusa de haber iniciado
incendios forestales recientes raval los
residentes parecieron lamentar la
decisión de
cortar lazos diplomáticos con argelia es
algo muy desafortunado
y es una mala decisión no hay razón para
hacerlo es como cortar relaciones con tu
vecino de al lado todos somos parte de
la unión del magreb el magreb united
contiene la tensión entre argelia
marruecos data de décadas las relaciones
diplomáticas ya han sido cortadas en el
pasado exactamente en 1976 una vez más
por la disputa alrededor del sáhara
occidental